yeah can you wear this top hat right
what's that committee created with the
little monocle Dior monocle Jiminy
Cricket damn I always thought I just
always called that the glass one glass
eye god I never called it that I have
never ever you go hey that monopoly guys
wearing one glass yeah they monopoly guy
with the one glass the Monica doesn't
have a what do you call a magnifying
glass yeah didn't he know it's the plan
you know what's so funny now what's a
call mandela mandela a fact
have you heard of the Mandela effect I
don't think aftermath um
Nelson Mandela Nelson but you have you
heard of the Mandela effect huh I mean
I've heard them a couple I gotta tell
you what a Mandela yes he didn't have
one I know so it's a it's a it's a it's
a theory it's a theory where our
realities have shifted right so things
that were true like 20 or 30 years later
are not true now like I'll give you an
exam give me example how do you spell
Froot Loops are you really a yeah yeah
yeah F are you i - yeah
l oo PS yeah that's you 100% believe
that that's what it's spelled yeah it's
not so basically what the theory is is
that we knew it it used to be Froot
Loops but there was a cosmic like a
shift and now it's called it's different
the way you spell Froot Loops yeah
it's fr oo t loops you just really want
to complicate life [ __ ] wait a minute Oh
explanation but it might have been it
might have wait they just changed it
later
[Laughter]
yeah yeah when you learn something when
you commit something to memory like the
correct spelling of fruit you're gonna
self correct it when you're it might
have been spelled like that that whole
time what it is fr are ot the whole time
the whole time but you just self correct
we sell correct to the equip that's a
theory there's no car though
oh look at the ship oh I see that's a
problem with people I think even if
there's a very simple answer in front of
them it's like they want their lives are
so [ __ ] meaningless that they would
rather blame it on a cosmic shift and
say hey you know what common sense that
is so I wouldn't force come say life is
like a box of chocolate or or or is it
life was like a box of chocolates laughs
is like a box of chocolates yeah well I
was my life was like a box of chocolate
collectiveness remembering what is yes
oh well he's saying that his mom told
him that right so what I hear and what I
thought was him saying like my mama
always said life as it is
yeah like a box of chocolate not was
yeah because you're you're seeing it
from point of him quoting his mother
rather than remembering it's something
she said in the past but it's not that
it's life was okay he never says it is
now can I go - if that's what can I go
check this oh yeah you can google it
it's always he'll if you go for us gum
ill say laughs was like it's but on some
boxes it still says it's intriguing it's
not some weird [ __ ] like thing that
he's making it out to be yeah because I
write now I don't know if I'm talking to
you or Sam Tripoli this is great right
yes okay so let me ask let me ask you
this
so oh I loves all right how long have
went that Sam's another one yeah
so going like why don't you tweet that
out to Tom Hanks and he'll tell you what
he said see this is the other thing you
[ __ ] yeah but some people phonetically
you know those think what are those that
thing what do you hear do you hear this
or that remember just recently Laura
Laura Laura Laura Laura no no
is Laurel and Yanni right I kept I heard
Laurel all the time so you can't go off
of watching the movie because some
people are gonna hear it was and some
people gonna hear is you tweet it out to
Tom Hanks and you say what was in the
script how is it written and what did
you say and that's the end
there's no the Earth's not gonna just
move you don't know what if he collected
he miss remembers - we should all tweet
after our fans tweet Tom Hanks yes and
then hashtag did you say life is like a
box or was it it's that simple and it
he'll go I actually have still you think
he doesn't have the script just curious
he still has the scripts it's a Curious
George have a tail or no tail he has a
tail he has no tail he has tail cos he
goes from the tree he has no tail no
well then here's what's happening you
know they also change animated
characters through the he's never had a
tail he does never a tail so I I know
baby I'm you're saying I can so I go
looking bad look at him so you just look
up Mandela fact and look at all the
examples it's really interesting
okay no I find this interesting all
right all right we're good all right so
how long we at Oh
we're gonna cut out a record it's a
record Wow well I don't need to be I
didn't need to do - I wanted you to do
two hours okay so give Johnny Sanchez a
run applause he was [ __ ]
[Music]